I think if only he let the inauguration
[Laughter]
oh that'd be great if they said if they
say you can do any jokes that you want
oh my god then we would do thank you
would you do it like co-headline with me
yeah but ten minutes a penis nor we'd
bomb I know it would be so fun everybody
laugh onstage together I would sit there
like Indian style watching yourself
right and everyone people fool you let
me just laughing I think that'd be great
there's no way it's good to talk about
here but that would be so scared you
know scared I'd be yeah I'd be terrified
I mean him and I back there going you
open you all I did a gig with Mike Young
and Mike Young set it up it was in
Venice you know Mike Young yeah right
and it was on a rooftop in in this like
beach house in Venice mm-hmm and they
had a mic and speakers on the roof and
then below right below there was a pool
party just during the day till right and
there was hundreds that like it's
hundreds of people there was a DJ and
then they go and I was supposed to go
first
mm-hm and then Mike Young was supposed
to go second so I go up and what's up
and they turned the music off and there
everyone's kind of looking up at me man
and then I do my said I'm bombing so
[ __ ] hard
mm-hm anyway this next guy um he's a
friend of mine he actually told me to do
this gig Mike Young and I turn around he
had left oh he left the [ __ ] game
yeah and I didn't talk to him for a year
I mean I was so livid that like number
one you set it up right number two you
leave me did you get paid he said yeah I
don't remember I don't remember part
like that was the biggest betrayal I've
ever seen yeah it's [ __ ] off yeah I
did a gig like that at Paramount Jamie
Masada set it up yeah yeah so it's like
yeah right Studios at the studios on a
Saturday night
all mine like everybody's on the lot
they have like a outside like dinner
party yeah and so the stage is here yeah
there's this huge fountain yeah
in the in the middle yeah then there's a
space yeah which is a dance floor and
then people are back here eating there's
like five comics yeah so who are they
can be the comic can't remember their
names
okay I tried her me they have you heard
of them before yeah yeah I bet Jerry bed
nap was one of them okay I think me and
him were last all right and then
somebody goes up bombs eats it yeah
nothing bring the other person up bombs
eats it nothing then the third person
goes up and I think I'm next
yeah that person bombs beats it nothing
yeah and then the lady who Jamie made
the show it comes up to me and Jerry and
said this isn't working out here's your
paychecks we're gonna end the show right
here oh and then then the other guys
came and our careers weren't it's a
great stopping point for the show was
Jamie there no he wasn't
of course he wasn't there and I wasn't
mad at him after how about three but
that watching the three comics you were
probably scared like what am I gonna do
what am I gonna yeah yeah yeah cuz sure
it wasn't it wasn't birthday parties I'd
like the country club yeah I had one Oh
Mike how do you wrangle people in a be
like everybody know II know folk I get
invited and a night club night I know it
was a contrary dude it was a country
club right I'm like a millionaire right
guys I'm like him
can you do comedy my it was a bachelor
party what was it so I show up really my
people are dancing you know no seats no
seats we're just dancing right and all
Shh
all right comedy mm-hmm and I go to
Gilbert he's going [ __ ]
he doesn't even up at the time
bullshitting people who don't care right
yeah it was a greatly catalytic her
though she was laughing to say come
closer come this way yeah come sit down
or do something yeah it was great for me
I was just cry laughing in the back and
then I went up and I don't know what the
[ __ ] I did but you didn't do your full
set you got naked I got naked right away
really quick cuz the money was so good
right I had to do something I couldn't
say really nice so nice I couldn't say I
don't want to do it mhm
you can keep the money right cuz it was
like such easy money and I had to do it
I'm sorry did you do ten fifty minutes
40 minutes bad I don't remember I I know
you blocked it out
how you block it out hey I know how to
do it were like this ain't going well so
I just go to the easiest jokes that I
have mm-hmm the switches you know
someone's jokes I don't even tell
anymore really and then you go right
into the getting naked and then it's you
shove the [ __ ] out of everybody yeah you
shut the [ __ ] everybody I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened and then you run
and grab the jack run out there it's
robbery yeah when I was in New York like
we used to do clubs a lot like dance
clothes
stop the music yeah and people gather
around you try to and that's why what
what like I was a different comic in New
York - I got louder your dreadlocks yeah
when I said this like yell everything
just to get the audience's attention
right and and then keep it you know and
then like at least scared him into now
heckling yeah it's funny that you say
that because I know that Joe when Rogan
when he was in Boston he wasn't doing
clubs he was like doing like bars and
stuff like that and he learned to really
like techniques to get an audience on
his side one of them was which I had
never heard at the time was you instead
of going that way right you go the
opposite way where you start kind of
talking softly yeah so that then people
kind of stopped talking just to listen
to what you're saying
which was an interesting you would think
that your gut instinct would be to go
talk over them but he told me that right
and I know a lot of commas that started
in the East Coast that started with more
of an aggressive style because that's
the conditions that they were in right
whereas I started in San Diego yeah yeah
but I did learn that technique though
like like when I do shows in England
yeah like it's like a bar culture and if
you yell they'll talk louder so they can
hear themselves talk yeah how did you
speak so you raised a raise you raised
but if you speak low then they'll be
aware and conscious of how loud they're
speaking and they'll take it down long
and then you could get people right and
it's like it feels like the weirdest
thing to do but it does work yeah yeah
[Music]